for once Hillary Clinton agrees with her
conservative critics she made a mistake
on Friday today she cleaned up her
version of grammy winter Barack Obama's
2012 hit you didn't build that making a
rare explicit reference to a
self-induced slip up but her mistake and
her Band-Aid bookended a weekend of
activity in Iowa New Hampshire in which
some other ambitious Democratic players
took the
stage I have no idea he would pack up
his truck and move to his vacation home
in New Hampshire
and run for S this is truly a historic
dinner and I look back and I have some
sense of who has spoken here before you
know Barack Obama Joe Biden John Cary or
as I like to call them my warmup acts
Chris Christie is actually here to film
a movie sequel the closed Bridges of
Madison County all right so in the last
couple of days we've had Martin o Ali
Joe Biden Elizabeth War Amy kober who
you saw there all hitting the first of
the nation hustings if Hillary Clinton
doesn't run in 2016 I think all of them
will probably run the question is is
Hillary Clinton feeling the heat she
made this error about talking about
corporations and businesses not creating
jobs John is she feeling heat or
altering her message because she's
feeling the the pressure from some of
those other people out there well I
think she's not feeling that much
pressure from those people out there
some of them like Amie kisher have
already urged her to run Elizabeth
Warren has urged her to run I don't
think it's the people that she's feeling
the heat from I think she's feeling some
of the heat from the base itself she's
reading some of the polls including
polling that we've done that suggest
that her closeness with Wall Street is a
problem for some of the democratic
nominating electorate and she's trying
to make some moves to inoculate herself
that against that criticism and that's
what led her into this mistake and
trying to get a little to Elizabeth
Warren the other night well and it shows
the pressure she's under and people who
say she benefits from not having an
opponent in the Democratic nomination
fight if she runs she gets so much
scrutiny you look at Marco Rubio Rand
Paul they're out there making mistakes
of the type she on Friday all the time
the problem for her is she's out there
getting criticized everybody's parsing
everything she says the performance of
those four of Biden and cliter and
Warren and Martin Aly they're all pretty
decent stump performers right now
they're not great they're not world
class necess but they're all pretty
decent and I think even if it's not
putting pressure on Hillary Clinton it
is reminding activists in those states
there are other voices in the party
they're out there now because there's
competitive races in both those States
gives them an excuse to go there I think
it it's it's helping them maybe it isn't
even if it's not hurting her but she
she's a smart woman and you're a smart
man and you don't really think any of
those people could beat her at a
democratic nominating Contest no none of
them could I don't think any of them
will try